Cuál es la situación actual de un año
después
buenas Muchísimas gracias la situación
después de un año
desafortunadamente como lo había dicho
acá se iba a empeorar y lo que me
preocupa es que todavía hay margen para
empeorar más la situación de Justicia
para el presidente es el Primer Ministro
es uno de los principales sospechoso en
el caso de ese magnicidio entonces La
idea es pasar la página
eso es la situación de hoy claro esta
página que no se ha pasado Haití todavía
intenta digamos recuperarse también de
Los huracanes de incluso del último
terremoto digamos Cuál es la situación
social en el país y que dice la gente
digamos en torno a este año el asesinato
de yoga en el Moisés realmente los
haitianos ya Se olvidaron de lo que
ocurrió Aquel aquel 7 de julio del año
2021 continúan digamos atentos a y
expectantes a las respuestas de de esta
investigación que que no ha llevado a
ningún punto por ejemplo
actualmente el golpe más duro a la
investigación fue que samia andar otro
sospechoso que fue arrestado en Turquía
hace poco fue liberado porque el
gobierno actual él dio un comunicado a
Turquía donde ellos insinúan En ese
mismo documento insinúan que samia andar
no va a encontrar un juicio justo en
Haití va a encontrar su situación en la
misma situación que están los
colombianos fue un comentario que había
hecho un juez que se llama hugherie pero
hablando con otro con otro compañero
Pero ellos toman esta misma situación le
le entregan este comunicado a Turquía y
Turquía suelta
andar y el pueblo por supuesto el pueblo
se siente muy como decepcionado en esta
situación y lo lo más grave por lo que
yo me Moisés fue asesinado fue la
situación de sus Jenner una empresa que
ganaba 12.000
12.000 12 millones de dólares mensual y
días después del asesinato este empresa
vuelve a cobrar los 12 millones mensual
hoy ya ha cobrado 144 millones de
dólares también el Luis estamos hablando
de este grupo de mercenarios o
contratados para poder llevar a cabo
este asesinato este magnicidio de El
entonces presidente de Haití y jovenil
Moisés Luis qué ha pasado digamos o con
toda esta investigación Y cómo un grupo
de mercenarios contratados se llegó a
perpetrar todo este los gérmenes de una
manera y pues prácticamente sin tanta
resistencia también le pregunto si se
baraja alguna otra manera de personas
internas al gobierno del presidente de
yovenil Moisés que pudieran estar
involucradas en todo lo que ocurrió el 7
de julio 2021 sin duda sin duda si no
fue así inclusive en Haití lo que se
habla es que el padrino de él lo entregó
Quién hace el Padrino El Padrino fue el
presidente que antes de él que le
entregó al poder y le dijo textualmente
y yo le entregó al poder
en 2022 usted me lo entrega tal cual
como te lo entregó Entonces yo me amois
no tenía ni siquiera poder para cambiar
su empleada doméstica todo lo que
trabajaba en la casa real lo colocaba El
Padrino Es decir
su el ex presidente del país Entonces no
había como proteger eh de ese asesinato
si si es algo que viene desde Neto
también Hablamos del Primer Ministro
actual Ariel Henry todavía no ha podido
solucionar esta crisis que vive Haití
tras este asesinato del presidente yo en
el Moisés porque no ha podido solucionar
porque no se ha podido sentar en la mesa
con los actores hay claves en este punto
no para llegar a un consenso digamos y
poder tener más al gobernabilidad más
más capacidad de poder controlar lo que
es Haití en este momento como les había
dicho
No no es su interés que que haya una
cual que haya menos tensión como les
había dicho el sospecho número uno del
asesinato es el Primer Ministro de hecho
de hecho después del asesinato la
persona que habla más con el primer
sospechoso el actor el actor material
del crimen que se llama Félix bayo la
persona que hablo más con feliz bayo
antes y después del crimen es el actual
fue mi Primer Ministro porque porque la
justicia por lo que está diciendo no
actúa o no se le pone la lupa al Primer
Ministro digamos tiene pues controlado
todos los poderes haitianos de este
Primer Ministro de hacer obviamente
difícil pues poder ir contra él que se
le Abre algún tipo de investigación o si
se le abrió y ya se cerró Cómo es el
caso en torno a esta acusación
de hecho
a hubo cinco veces sobre sobre este caso
Yo creo que el tercer juez que tenía el
caso le invitó al Primer Ministro para
contestar las preguntas que tenía sobre
su nombre sobre su teléfono que había
hablado con el sospechoso Félix bayo lo
que hizo la reacción del Primer Ministro
fue revocar o suspender al West que le
invitó